all right good morning everyone Welcome
to our regular meeting
um
looks like we have a quorum
and representative groda should be
sitting in for
representative Leon
okay
the minute from the previous meeting
I need comments or Corrections
all right seeing none
those in favor
hi hi those are those opposed
all right the emotion carries
and
it's the consent agenda does anyone wish
to remove something from the consent
agenda
any discussion on the consent agenda
okay are those in favor
aye opposed
okay motion passes
regular agenda
plant and property rules
so this particular proposal had 14
substantive comments and three comments
to jailcar
um a number of the comments had to do
with the discrepancy between the forms
and the language and the rules as none
of the forms were Incorporated by
reference so there's a legislative
intent unclear comments on pages 10 25
27 74 77 87 and 95 regarding those
comments and I have broken down each
comment if the committee would like to
hear each one individually
please sure so the first one on page 10
has to do with the vendor application
on the form there's a requirement for a
done number and for the vendor's
appropriate designation
Additionally the agency also has this
form available on the New Hampshire
first
platform and so the formatting is a
little different but there's still a
discrepancy as the New Hampshire first
printout that was provided to oil OLS
also has a request for the vendors
appropriate designation which is not in
the rules this could be fixed by
incorporating this form by reference as
opposed to laying it out in the rules
which could be addressed in a
conditional approval request
on page 25
the rule calls the form a service
contract proposal transmittal letter
form but the document that was submitted
to OLS is titled State of New Hampshire
bid transmittal letter so there's a
discrepancy on what it's called
additionally
as um
some of the new members may not be aware
there is a difference between a contract
in a form a form is considered a rule
under the statute but a contract is
specific to certain entities and not all
entities so this particular form
we have
looked at it it is in the rules and it's
called a form so we've considered it
form however it does seem as though it
is specific to
what sort of bid the department has put
out what they're looking for what the
requirements are so there is quite a bit
of changes between each form this is
also something that was noted on page
seven of the final proposal as a note to
jail car
um the department had submitted a form
number p37 which is the first form in
the link labeled FP forms two
that despite being called a form it's
not mentioned in the rules specifically
it is instead referenced in the
definition for requirement of a bid and
because of that we considered that more
of a contract as opposed to a form
because once again it was specific to
what the department was requesting what
they were asking for and what they were
receiving back from their vendors and
it's not laid out in the rules as a form
on page 27 there's a reform called a
request for quotation the rule states
that a statement signed under the
penalty of unsworn falsification must be
submitted
and the form that was provided to OLS
States this on the second page of the
form
but there's nowhere on the form to sign
and there's no language on it for
the vendor to sign under the penalty of
unsworn falsification
on page 74 for the hard drive
disposition form it asks for the make
and model of the hard drive on the form
but the rule does not have these
requirements once again this is an easy
fix that could be done by just
incorporating that form by reference in
a conditional approval request
page 77 the surplus vehicle checklist
and once again there's just a minor
discrepancy as the form asks for the VIN
number where the rule asks for the body
style of vehicle
also an easy fix with an incorporation
by reference and a conditional approval
request page 87 is a writer to agreement
form the form states that you are
um
that if you were check that you're in
the special milk program you cannot
participate in the program
but that is not clear on the rules
that's not stated in the rules that if
you are a participant in this program in
the special milk program you can't
continue on with the writer agreement
form so that was unclear between the
form and the rule
and on page 95 there is a form
called a participation form
in the rule but the form itself doesn't
have a title it's just States at the Top
If you're not participating please check
and then it has a list so there's no
actual title on that particular form
so that was those particular issues with
regard to the legislative intent on
clear comments
moving on there's an unclear comment on
page 30. as there's no requirement in
the introductory language so the
language is unclear as written
on page 71 there is the first time
mentioned a declaration of surplus form
and then on page 75 there's a full
description of what this form requires
however OLS was informed by the
department that this form no longer
exists and that a report is generated
through the New Hampshire first by the
agency directly instead therefore these
rules need to be Rewritten to remove the
reference to the Declaration of surplus
form and instead put in what is actually
being submitted to the agency or what
the agency is requiring be submitted in
that report through the New Hampshire
first
on page 82 there is another unclear
comment with regard to missing
requirements in the introductory
language
there's three particular sections on
that page sections a b and c which all
are missing that language so they are
unclear as written
on pages 86 and 88 this is another
instance of
um forms not being listed or there's
forms listed with requirements in the
rules but the agency has informed OLS
that these forms are no longer in use as
this particular program is now handled
by the Department of Education those two
forms are the Commodities in lieu of
cash statement and the Civil Rights
compliance review form therefore these
rules have to be Rewritten to remove
those particular forms from the rules
on page 94 there's a note to jail carve
which is just an informational note
regarding that the prices have not
changed in that particular rule from the
previous version to this version
on page 101 there's another unclear
comment because there are two paragraphs
paragraphs o and P which were not in the
initial proposal but were added into the
final proposal
and they were not
um
mentioned in the agency's initial notice
the notice only states that that
particular section is being re-adopted
so that it's on the same expiration
timeline as the rest of the rules
in talking with the person who was doing
the initial proposal
before leaving the agency
that person informed me that there was
no public comments made at the hearing
so this particular change is not based
on a public comment
um he had thought that perhaps it had to
do with some sort of federal compliance
but I was not able to get any
clarification from anyone at the agency
on why exactly these two paragraphs were
added
um additionally this is not a comment
made on the FP but in addition those
paragraphs and introduce a new
compliance report and the there was
nothing submitted to OLS regarding
what that report is what it looks like
anything of that nature
and the final comment is another note to
jailcar on page 127 once again it's just
an informational comment informing the
committee about those particular reports
stated being
explicitly not considered a form under
541a
so that's why that there was no comments
made with regard to those forms
lovely
is there anyone here from
from the agency
okay
suggestions okay
representative Senator Lang moves a
preliminary objection based on staff
comments is there a second
okay representative Schmitz seconds
fine representative hatch seconds then I
know which side it was on
um
is there any discussion about that
I'd like to comment that these rules
were updated by a person who has left
the agency and therefore there I imagine
they're struggling to to fill that
position
but uh nonetheless they should
with the with the helpful notes provided
by the staff they should be able to deal
with it
uh any anyone else
no no okay representative hacken
Phillips has shown up and she shoots it
in for Senator uh Whitley I believe
yes
well in that case you're you're sitting
in for Senator Ennis
okay
any further discussion on on the
objection
those in favor
aye opposed
okay thank you very much and the next
step is the therapeutic cannabis
registry rules
okay so um this proposal makes changes
to the registry rules there are two
items to discuss the first is on page
six of the PDF packet which is also page
one of the rule
um this comment and that's at the top of
the page
um this comment is letting you know that
the proposal implements four of the five
bills out of the 2021 and 2022
legislative sessions
and what's missing is the implementation
of hb605 which amended the statute to
allow out-of-state people holding
medical cannabis cards in other states
to purchase in New Hampshire and my
understanding is that there might be
some difficulty with implementing this
and I'm sure the department can answer
any questions around that and then I'll
move on to the next one if that's okay
foreign
thank you very much for the record my
name is Michael Holt I'm the
administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program and I also oversee the
prescription drug monitoring program for
the division of Public Health Services
which is a program that moved over to
HHS and
July of 2021 via house bill 2.
um
thank you Kim for the comment um it is
true that we are behind on implementing
this legislation
um including the the visiting qualifying
patient law
um I'm happy to report that rules
rulemaking has is underway we'll be
filing those rules with
um with LBA hopefully next week they're
with the commissioner now for review so
we expect a uh are we you know depending
on the progress of that rule we should
be uh targeting the
the May gel car for that implementation
the reasons for the delay include things
I'm sure you've heard about well this is
a self-funded program the therapeutic
cannabis program we have minimal staff
working on it
um we have we've had vacancies over the
past couple years and there's a
Statewide Workforce shortage there's
just simply more work than we can we can
handle with the Staffing that we have
but we are moving forward
um and hopefully by uh by uh late spring
we'll have that in place
okay it would be fair to say that you
deliberately left that one out while you
concentrated on incorporating the other
other legislative changes uh it's a
different rule set um the visiting
qualifying patient rules impact um HEC
402 which is the rules that regulate the
alternative treatment centers so it is
it is a different rule set there is a
small amount of overlap between those
two proposals and so the next proposal
you will see a couple of sections in 401
that are impacted
um but it's a it's a different rule set
thank you does anyone else have any
questions
all right where have you been
answer my question
29 Hayes and drive sure
every day just welcome back Michael it's
good to see you thank you
okay
um so the other issue is on page 32 of
the PDF packet
um which is Page 27 of the role and the
comments on the bottom of that page
okay so um this section of the role um
the paragraph B describes when the
agency will revoke a person's registry
card and it says that if a person has
violated the statute's prohibition on
obtaining more than two ounces in a
10-day period that the department will
revoke after sending notice and giving
the person an opportunity to respond and
if they violate the statute more than
two times
while the statute is pretty clear that a
person shall not obtain more than two
ounces within a 10-day period it also
grants the agency some discretionary
Authority around revoking registry cards
including for this particular violation
so here the agency is using that
discretion by providing notice a chance
to respond and then revoking for more
than two violations the agency says that
the intent is to revoke for repeat and
intentional violations so
um that's the only comment I had on that
one I'm sure the agency can talk a bit
more about that
Ms Reeve has captured the issue
correctly and um
I'm happy to answer questions about the
the policy that we're proposing here um
the department has statutory discretion
um we have you know follow the manual in
terms of a shall revoke if certain
conditions are met
um and it is absolutely Our intention to
not revoke a patient's card due to an
accident uh and so this uh this policy
provides a due process
um gives to people people you know two
chances
um and and the goal is to uh to to
enforce this statutory provision for
intentional violations
Senator again I I my question was for
the attorney again they're within
statute with this rule it just it's a
May versus a shall so that this
discretion is all we're calling out
making sure that at least as the rule
goes we know that we're granting
discretion to the agency by the rule
yeah correct the the statute I can read
it real quick it says the department May
revoke the registry identification card
of a qualifying patient or designated
caregiver for violation of rules adopted
by the department or for a violation of
any other provision at this chapter
including for obtaining more than two
ounces of cannabis in any 10-day period
in violation of RSA 126 10 8 and the
qualifying patient or designator
designated caregiver shall be subject to
any other penalties established in law
for this violation so I read that
section as granting the department
discretion how they choose to you know
enforce that particular you know
Prohibition in the statute
and so by doing that it allows the
agency to be able to investigate and
then only act on intentional as you said
versus accidental
um or unintentional and that's the way I
read it yes sir thank you any other
questions comments
please continue
that was all I had that's all you had oh
right move to a proof
with staff edits
a couple and door fixes in there the
editorial comments yes any discussion
comments questions
second
seeing none the motion is to approve the
rule as corrected by staff comments
um those in favor
aye aye opposed
all right thank you very much just to be
clear that sounds like it's a
conditional approval correct okay it was
a straight approval so I just wanted to
make sure okay yes
we'll see you in a couple months
good luck on finding the staff
all right
Health and Human Services
okay
um so the next one
um this rule describes the licensing
facility and service requirements for
hospice houses a conditional approval
has been filed and it resolves all the
issues except for one which is that the
rules have been expired since 2017. so
the committee may have some questions
about enforcement of the rules during
the time period of expiration I will
note that the statute does set up a
specific licensing fee so they didn't
need to have any rules in place to
enforce the licensing fee in case there
were any questions around that but
that's all I had
hi good morning my name is Kelly Keith
I'm the licensing supervisor at the
Bureau of Licensing and certification
this rule is expired but as the attorney
mentioned we do have the authority in
RSA 151 to accept that application and
renew their license annually there are
two hospice homes in New Hampshire and
they're both federally certified by CMS
therefore regulated and enforced through
federal regulations
if they're regulated through Federal
Regulations why are we bothering to do
anything
because state law requires them to be
licensed as well
be added to the governor's list later
exactly all right well thank you so the
fee is in statute the regulation is in
federal federal rules and the
um
the corrective
the corrective uh Amendment solves all
the other issues any discussion
one two three
oops representative Schmidt moves to
approve
second
okay
any discussion
all in favor
aye opposed
all right thank you very much thank you
and the Board of Education
um so this
is it was actually on the consent but
due to
[Music]
um
some timing with the Board of Education
the um the agency asked for it to be
postponed so your deadline is March 21st
and the next meeting is on March 20 uh
March 17th so you just need to vote to
postpone
move the postpone
any discussion
okay those in favor
aye opposed
all right we are postponed
sorry I missed it
all right so the criminal history record
checks
there was only one comment with regard
to these rules
um it's a note to gel car and a
legislative intent comment as these
rules were part of interim rule 2022-3
they expired back on October 23rd of
2022 so the committee may have questions
on how the department has been
conducting criminal history checks since
they've expired additionally
their committee may have questions on
whether the department has been
collecting fees under uh Ed
505.09 which is the educator fees in
violation of RSA
541a221 as the feasts are set in the
rules and not the statute the statute
specifically gives the board the
authorization to create rules and create
those fees but there's no set fees in
the statute
good morning Steve Appleby division
director for the division of educator
support in higher education one of the
programs that I oversee is Educator
licensure to which these rules apply we
became aware that the rules had expired
on January 24th and immediately stopped
collecting fees or applications at that
point in my research during the eight
roughly eight weeks that these rules
were expired we processed 739
applications and collected approximately
fifty seven thousand eight hundred in
fees during that time
we made a mistake we didn't realize we
had a changeover in staff and didn't
realize that when an interim rule
expires it expires the underlying rule
unlike an emergency rule which doesn't
do that so once we became aware we
immediately stopped so today we are not
processing educator licenses
we are in a holding pattern and have
been since January 24th
and what is your attention with the
fifty thousand dollars or so that you've
collected illegally yes
um waiting on our legal counsel to
instruct us on how to do refunds I guess
would be the right answer there
thank you so it's expired and you you've
you're not issuing any licenses what
about those that need a license and and
what quandary are they left in that you
have to continue to provide the service
right here we are yes again yes
um so
um we again as I said became aware on
the 24th which is a little over three
weeks ago we have 60 days in State
Statute to process a license so up to 60
days we don't we typically take two or
three days but we have up to 60. so
we're still within that 60-day window
and the districts all are aware that it
can take longer sometimes there are
complicated applications
um depending on the the Educators
schooling background they may have gone
to multiple colleges and we have to do
an in-depth transcript analysis so it
can take sometimes a little longer than
a few days so
we're okay at the moment
is the short answer
assuming of course that we have proved
the rule today yes thank you yes
John Schmidt well representative hatch
started on the issue that I wanted to
raise and that is what is the impact you
guys are okay but the question is what
are the applicants doing in the interim
is it what impact is this going to have
on functioning of this the various
different individuals and their their uh
their activities
yes so um to date we know we know of no
instances where this has caused an
applicant's Financial issues
um there is a provision elsewhere an
administrative rule at the department
that allows a district to employ a
substitute teacher for up to 20
consecutive days work days without a
license
so we only have I believe it's
four cases currently of districts
pending holding off on hiring an
individual due to this issue but all
four of those individuals are working as
substitute teachers currently within
those districts
is there a financial impact to them not
at this time no if if we go past and we
don't move forward then of course that
will begin to stack up so they're
they're making the same amount of money
that they would be entitled to if they
were licensed my understanding in
talking to those superintendents is
they've worked out an agreement and yes
it's not so you have engaged with those
individuals in the entities involved yes
we actually have wording in our
licensure system that directs any
applicant with a pending employment
situation to contact us directly
and as I say we've had War so you
understand that you're on the record
with regard to your remarks and and the
answers to our questions thank you
thank you I was a little confused when I
heard that the rules are expired but we
have a final proposal in front of us but
they only heard three weeks ago that
realized that it was expired like can
you tell me when it actually expired yes
so the rule expired October 23rd
okay and we we asked for a waiver to to
get on the agenda sooner than is normal
okay thank you I was thinking for a
moment that they were protected under
549a 14-a which would mean if the
they filed the initial proposal before
the rule expired they would be okay but
apparently that not so lucky yeah
Senator move to a group
any any further discussion questions
okay motion to approve
those in favor
aye opposed
thank you very much and thank you I
would appreciate a report on what you're
doing with those fees exactly
foreign
so and we have the state police toe list
here
yes before the agency speaks so this is
on our docket because of me
unfortunately
um I was contacted we had passed this
law
um I think two years ago that required
State Police to create a rotating tow
list for
um accidents and such on the highway
that they have to call a tow truck for
in order to create Equity so there
wasn't any anything going on somehow it
got in in the rule in in the state can
talk to it but the state police but in
the rule making they got slowed down and
hampered by some problems which they
finally worked out and we've got at
least a set of Draft rules that they
need to implement in order to comply
with the statute and that's why they're
available so
yes tomorrow thank you
um when this first came in I uh staff
reviewed it as we always do to make sure
that there is an actual basis for an
emergency rule which is limited to an
emergency that affects public health or
safety uh or uh significant economic
impact to the state or its citizens and
because they've been in our year and a
half lag I wasn't sure if there was an
emergency today that wasn't there
shortly after the bill passed
thank you and I have to say that when I
read their cover sheet I was
startled to notice they say they're
ignoring the law and just calling people
as they wish
good morning
thank you uh good morning I'm attorney
Dave hiltz from the Department of Safety
I'm here covering uh for attorney modic
beginning who could not be here today
um respectfully this is quite an odd
situation I mean as attorney Morrow
pointed out the legislation on this was
originally enacted approximately a year
and a half ago and the factors at the
time that you know warranted the passage
of the statute that's quite a long
period of time you know to go without
implementing the uh the problem that
Senator Lang mentioned that sort of
slowed things up and actually posed a
significant concern for us in
implementing the statute was that in
106 b33
um the the legislation that passed
allocated the costs of Towing and
storage of vehicles to State Police
under certain situations
um that language is not in the uh
version of the bill that State Police
had engaged with people on they were
surprised to see that in there
and the thought was if we moved forward
under this entire scheme that that
provision would be operative and we
could not accept being stuck with the
cost of those toes so we went about
engaging other people you know
legislators again to try to get this
fixed when it did get fixed effective
July 2022 it was such a very small part
of the bill that had been changed and I
don't know who all had the discussions
because I wasn't directly involved with
the thought was that it really didn't
support interim rulemaking because the
overwhelming majority of the statutory
scheme hadn't changed since you know
October of 2021 which is well outside
the 180 days to do interim rulemaking so
um the decision was to do emergency
rulemaking
um you know there was some discussions
with Senator Lang but as we wrote it up
in the cover sheet and as I Was
preparing for this today
um you know really all of these benefits
the for the for the fiscal in for the
fiscal impacts to citizens to the
industry and also the beneficial impacts
of Public Safety they're all in the
statute the statute's very detailed uh
obviously a lot of thought went into
that about how best to protect you know
the citizens fiscal interests their
property you know provide for their
Public Safety with criminal records
checks and things like that so in our
opinion based on kind of the unique
facts that got us here the emergency is
just getting those benefits out there
and ineffective as soon as possible
um and not you know waiting the
additional you know four months to do
this in regular rule making from the
outset obviously the committee will you
know have us back for the regular
rulemaking you know for any and all you
know reasons that they see fit but
um
that's the the play of the land as I
understand it and we respectfully ask
that if you'd allow this um to go
through that any remaining issues that
you might have we can address on regular
rulemaking
have you started regular rulemaking
um I actually don't know the answer to
that question since I'm covering for
attorney Modigliani
um but I can I can find that out for you
afterwards please represent Morrow our
director
for the newer members I just I think
this is the first emergency rule you've
seen an emergency rule as I told you the
basis it goes into effect as soon as
it's filed with our office I mean the
minute it is filed there is no public
comment uh there's no no hearing by
Statute and the committee cannot approve
or object to an emergency rule if it
feels there's no basis for an emergency
then it can petition the agency to
repeal the rule but that is the
ultimately is the decision of the
department whether to do so or not
that's a very rare event where Joker
actually petitions an agency but also
for the Department's benefit if you do
exceed the 180 day deadline with new
legislation you can request a waiver
from the director of legislative
Services if you have good cause
foreign
making note of the fact that that uh
this situation exists and uh we'd
certainly like to hear back ASAP with
regard to your communication with Martha
madigrian
yes
thank you I'll let the committee know
ASAP you know whether or not we've
started regular rulemaking
um I can do that you know this morning
after I get back to the office thank you
and I try
yeah
I I'm kind of shocked that you're
description of the emergency says we're
not going to pay any attention to the
law until we get the rules going and I'm
not sure I consider that an appropriate
position
may I respond to that please
um so so it
we're not Cavalier at the department of
safety it's not our position that we can
simply ignore the law it it's a quandary
that we were in in terms of trying to
implement a law that we didn't expect
you know there was as I understand it
engagement you know with the agency and
the industry and the legislature on this
bill and however it happened it was a
complete surprise to us that this you
know fiscal impact part of the bill made
it in there that made us responsible for
for these costs so you know when we went
about you know trying to decide how to
best fix this and get things implemented
it wasn't like oh yeah we can just
ignore the law I understand objectively
that's the effect but that's not that
wasn't our approach it's just how do we
how do we fix this how do we get through
this without being subject to the part
of the law that never really should have
been in there in the first place so I
apologize that you know the the effect
of
how the department chose to handle this
you know could be seen objectively as
ignoring the law but I can assure you
that that was not
how we approached it intent wise
thank you Senator gray uh certainly by
your statement you talked about the
money and I also sit on fiscal and if
had you come to fiscal and said okay I
had this law I need to implement it
okay at least you would have gotten the
fiscal committee to say no we're not
going to spend the money right now and
you would have been off the hook but
right now you are on the hook and I
think that at least the letter should
come from us or from the attorneys here
that say that your your reason for the
ignoring the law is uh
at least justify it in some means or
come to physical and ask for the money
thank you are there any other comments
questions yes sir Senator so so the
other thing I again one of the
conversations we had when I met with I
met with director Edwards
um and and and the lieutenant and the
conversation was around the motoring
public and safety of the motoring public
and having the ability to know who's
showing up as well as the rotation you
know in law enforcement that's always as
a former cop that's always been an issue
in local communities that who you call
for a tow and do the cop call his best
buddies he have a rotation that all
businesses are able to get a part of
that business and so that was the
reasoning around some of this Lo this
law so I I do think that this is in the
best interest of the citizens and there
is a good reason to move it forward now
and not wait another six months while
the rule making process is going on that
we should allow this this to happen to
protect our motor in public
thank you and I would like to say that
I'm not I understand that concern I am
more concerned with their statement
saying division is utilizing tow
businesses that have not been vetted as
required under the applicable statutes
that's of significant concern
and uh
director mortal if you could draft a
letter from from the committee saying
that that we're concerned about this
partly on the grounds that Senator gray
brought up and partly that they appear
not to be following the law is
okay I'll do that and then forward it to
you for an approval
nothing much else we can do with that
one
I think someone else was just to make a
speech
all right moving on thank you very much
okay so um the next discussion item
um is on the prescription drug
affordability board uh back in November
the committee conditionally approved new
rules which Implement RSA 126 BB which
establishes the prescription drug
affordability board and it included a
request that the board report back to
the committee on the benefits of
benefits associated with the fees being
assessed by the board pursuant to the
statute the committee requested this
because it received a copy of a 2013
memorandum written by UNH law professor
Marcus Hearn written to house Ways and
Means on the limits of the general
Court's power under the New Hampshire
Constitution to raise revenue
concern was expressed at the meeting
that the annual assessment fees have no
benefit to the entities and could
possibly be unconstitutional just to be
clear what we're talking about is not
the administrative fees for supplies or
copying and stuff like that what we're
talking about is two different annual
assessment fees one is no less than one
hundred dollars for insurers hmos and
third-party administrators the second
one is no less than 500 on pbms drug
manufacturers and wholesalers
um so in in looking at the statute and
the legislative history and and the rule
um the fees might be unconstitutional
because they appear not to have a
benefit associated with them
um to the entities paying the fees
um they're not fees for licenses they're
not user fees they aren't taxed on
property or income they don't qualify as
cost recovery they appear to be a fee
for doing business in New Hampshire but
the legislative history does not talk
about the purpose of the fees at all
it's completely silent and that said the
board has filed a memo which is in the
packet and it lays out some potential
benefits to the payers which includes
like increased transparency which could
possibly lead to a reduction in cost
more cost-effective Alternatives
available and potentially an increase in
market share which may outweigh the um
the assessment fees the memo also points
out that a statute is presumed
constitutional and that parties
challenging them have the burden to
prove
so it I don't think anybody from the
board is present today to join in on the
discussion or to talk about their memo
but that is
um the the item and if anybody has any
questions we can we can try to answer
those
son of hatch has a question or comment
attention and if you stated that I
apologized for missing it but also and
part of this in in
I think most of the staff is aware of my
concern over fees as they come in and
that they're appropriate because a fee
has to be uh directly related to the
cost of providing a service if it's not
um it's a tax and with this I I uh my
head exploded about nine times when I
saw what was being assessed uh no 10
excuse me I was in the hospital so it
was okay
um but
has there been any attention paid to
that because this whole thing is just
upside down in my mind
right
um no I'm I in in their memo they they
talk a lot about you know the in the
memo by stating that the statute is
presumed constitutional until it isn't
it's up to the parties to challenge it
um they just talk about these you know
theoretical potential benefits
associated with the fees but there
appears to be no concrete you know
benefit to the entities
well benefit that's that's separate than
actual cost to fee car has to be
directly related to the cost of the
service being provided if it's not it's
a tax
you are plain and simple right and and
um I think this needs a lot of
review
I believe I I would agree with you but
when I look through that the statute
specifically says not less than a
hundred dollars for these people not
less than five hundred dollars for these
people
um they are following the statute which
they are also required to do so I would
say the board is at a bind yes and what
we should be doing is looking at the
statute and saying does this make sense
okay thank you I agree senator
so thank you so again the other thing
that's interesting about this is that we
already charged these entities fees over
an insurance department in order to do
business in the state
so we're charging them not only at the
insurance department to get a license so
they can do business without charging
them at this board so they can do
business in the state so I guess what
I'd ask I guess I'll try to make this in
the form of emotion is that we recommend
to the legislature that they review and
and make possible legislative changes so
on that statute
yeah I'll second that that seems to me
to make a lot I tend to agree with
representative McGuire that if it's in
the law then you know it's not our role
to
to uh to give the the agency that's
that's drafting regulations consistent
with the law a hard time about doing
that but I do think for the reasons
everybody stated that maybe the law
ought to be changed so I have second uh
Senator Lang's uh motion and it's and
it's pretty clear from the board's
response that there is no clear obvious
benefit to the people who are paying the
fees
because if there was they would have
stated it right okay Madam chair one
more thing there's two bills pending on
this agent on this board so there's
place for the legislature act this year
if they choose to excellent we will
draft up such a letter immediately
um
that we have a motion is there any
further discussion
those in favor
aye opposed
all right so
Jen
is there any other business I don't know
senator
yes would the committee take a vote as
to whether to uh
eliminate the secondary meeting
yes
those in favor of counseling the
committee the continued meeting say aye
aye opposed
thank you we will not do that
and if there's no further business we we
are adjourned
good to know
for the newer members uh we have passed
out
sent packets of orientation materials
but if anyone would like to come into
our office and sit down and have a brief
orientation we'd be happy to do that